talk a little bit about what are some of
the challenges and opportunities
especially applying this type of skill
the technical computational programming
you know data science skills to big data
so the first thing that i would start
with is that
surprisingly we have access to
a lot of high quality data sets not only
are these data sets
generated by experts in excellent labs
the data sets continuously update so we
have
new and more detailed understanding of
different
areas of life sciences through the lens
of these
data for example just in this pandemic
we have a tremendous growth not only in
the quantity and quality of data but
also the rate of data submission so
if you compare this to previous
pandemics like
the sars1 ebola virus mers or zika
this pandemic has generated so much data
in almost real time
and has made that data accessible to
almost anyone that would like to now the
question is not so much about
data availability but what to do with
this data
to extract meaningful insights and
that's where i think
these skills really come together so
first of all data could be
of many different types it could be
imaging data clinical data
streaming data omix data chemical
phenotypic there
are really many different types of data
but for all of them
one of the first challenges is to create
structured
data that you can actually work with and
so to do that
the first thing that we will talk about
is how to take these different types of
data including phenomena phenotypic data
genomics
variant data epigenomics different types
of histone modifications dna methylation
transcriptomic data gene expression and
things like that and how to take that
information
and start processing it creating
structured
tables and those tables could come in
different formats they could be matrices
with just numbers they could be data
frames with both numbers
and different types of levels for
factors
or names and now that we have
the structured data now the second
challenge
is really to be able to ask the right
kinds of
questions about this data right nobody
just takes data
and structures it so that you can
you know visually see what's in it right
everybody works with data
to be able to answer some important
questions and that's another
part of data science that i think
differentiates
a data technician from a data scientist
the science
is really all about asking questions
that are supported by evidence
and so the data exists to help us
extract evidence from the data set
but for us to have a relevant question
what we want to do in this program is to
introduce you to some of those critical
and important
interesting questions that could be
asked of these types of data sets
so that you can really utilize the data
effectively and so
what we hope that this program can
provide for you
is a complete roadmap for data science
that will be
an application to biomedical research
data but it will include
things like finding different data sets
learning how to explore and visualize
these data sets to understand
major characteristics of the data how to
understand different types of research
methods that others use
and extract the evidence that you need
to answer a research
question and ultimately how to showcase
or
illustrate what you have found with
relevant
methods of insights so that you can
visualize your data so that you can
identify
the properties the statistical
properties to point to and
ultimately lead to understanding so
we call this program ominix logic
because
really it combines the omics data and
the
practical skills with a logical approach
and it guides you from a to b
from knowing about all of these terms
and wanting to apply them
to actually understanding of how to
apply them and then demonstrating what
you have learned
so we'll take several different types of
projects
using biomedical omnics data from
diagnostics in cancer biology
single cell and tissue composition
microbiome and
infection and in the context of these
different types of topics
we will learn about your typical data
analysis skills that you would have to
learn
to use effectively to extract meaningful
insights
including data collection so how is the
data collected
what does it represent data cleaning
how do you extract only the relevant
information
or the good quality data right
and make it tidy and ready for analysis
how to perform
exploratory data analysis and how to
iterate that process so that the
insights
come from the data data driven questions
and hypotheses that you can generate and
then how to
explore the data in in a way that you
can really
apply statistical modeling and inference
from
those models so that you can get
meaningful results
and obviously a big part of that is
going to be focused
on data mining in classification so
we will learn about different types of
unsupervised and supervised techniques
that have been used extensively on their
own
but also as a part of meaningful
bioinformatics work
and the principles of data science
that include statistics and data
wrangling are going
to be very meaningful here when we go to
machine learning because
you will essentially operate with an
extraction from different
portions of the data to train your model
to validate your findings to make sure
that your model
is accurate and you will learn to
differentiate between different types of
methods
so that you can compare and contrast the
results and select the ones that are
most appropriate to the type of
problem that you're solving now the same
methods are
also included in many different types of
biological data mining and those include
things like differential gene expression
or principal
component analysis and standard tools
that
are adapted from these methods to
address more and more technical
variation and complexity in the types of
data that is being
collected including integration of
multinomics data
but also including more and more
advanced data types like single cell
data and data that combines multiple
elements together
and so that's why we really are going to
be looking at
a variety of applications for
multi-omics data integration and
integration of this
omix data with clinical data using the
different examples that we will try
so to give you an overview of what this
program is going to
look like i would like to take you to
the program page so
uh for all of you involved uh
sorry let me go over here okay
so um everyone that is interested
to join this program the easiest way
to show you what this program is going
to include
is to take you to the program page so
this is a
program page uh it is called lbrn
omixologic data science
and so i'll just explain what is lbrm
mean lbrn stands for louisiana
biomedical research network our major
partner in this program
and the uh because of their support we
are
able to make this program more
accessible to more people
and so um the types of information that
you will
get on this page are going to i think
address many of the questions that you
might have
joining today's webinar so first of all
the program is going to start
on july 12th and last for a month
and during this time we will cover a
number
of different topics by participating in
live sessions like today
where you can interact with the mentors
and
get answers to your question as well as
practice
in class to perform different types of
analysis
you will also be able to
use a synchronous resources in between
our sessions
to gain more technical skills
at your own flexible schedule so in many
cases
we will go through a portion of the
material
by going through them in our session and
then we will
point you to resources that you can
supplement this knowledge with
by performing actual technical steps of
writing the code trying to run the code
getting the outputs and even
troubleshooting some of your results
so to illustrate how that part of it
will work
let me ask you how many of you already
have an account
on onyxlogic so please if you do have an
account
uh maybe you can put in number one in
the chat
if you okay great thank you leanna
if you don't have an account just take a
minute to register
the way you register is you go to login
and you create an account right here on
this form
after you've created the account you
will have access
to the coursework that we will discuss
okay great
excellent so i see that a lot of you
already have this
and once you're logged in you will be
able to see
uh yes you will be able to see some of
the courses that are
going to be included in this program
okay so is there anyone
here that have not
registered yet
is there anyone here that has not
registered yet
okay if you could take a moment and
register please we'll give it just a
couple of minutes
so everyone is able to uh follow through
some of the examples
that we will be going through
okay so once you are logged in
you will be redirected to a page where
you see a collection of courses
that are linked to your profile and what
i will demonstrate
is how we will leverage some of these
resources to actually
practice what we are going to do in this
program
okay so i see that someone is raising
their hands
and would you like to
ask something
okay okay so
um if you're already inside
on the course page
please search for data science
and you will see here a couple of
courses
data science introduction to data
science and python and an introduction
to data science in r
okay so once you are in these courses
you will be able to see what types of
methods we're going to be covering
and even try some of them with a free
registration so
if you register today or you already
have been registered before
you can access all of the free courses
and then
when you complete your registration and
there's a number of ways that you can
register that i'll talk about
you will see courses with this star and
those would be premium courses that
address some of the more advanced topics
and require some more practice
so you'll be able to access those with a
premium subscription
one of the things that is always
difficult
with large complex data sets is to grasp
the type of information or the type of
relevant
information that is in the data quickly
not spending a lot of time on individual
feature
like a gene and more looking for general
trends so what i want to show you today
briefly
is an example from a course on
dimensionality reduction
principle component analysis and
visualization
now principal component analysis is most
useful
for continuous data which means that
the data is in a numeric form
just like you see inside the cells over
here
and it could be anywhere in a continuous
scale
from zero to whatever the maximum is and
it doesn't even have to be zero it could
be also centered so it could be
minus one to one or it could be uh
negative and positive numbers but the
key point here
is that it is continuous data and so the
continuous data is represented here in
this example
as a gene expression profile for
a number of different groups as you can
see right here we have
a row for groups and we have sample ids
which are essentially
names of cell lines that have different
properties so they come from different
breast cancer patients and so using this
example what you'll see in this course
is how you can apply a principal
component analysis technique
to quickly evaluate the separation of
samples into different groups based
on this gene expression profile that is
found inside the data matrix which is
just the numeric portion of this table
of this data frame that we were looking
at just a moment ago
so you have a brief video that you can
go through to really understand the
challenge of the process to getting to
this outcome but also you have a
breakdown of the full code now for many
people including myself
one of the main challenges in learning
data science
is that most of the courses out there
start with
very basic things like learning how to
print out hello
world in our case we're assuming that
you are ready to jump beyond that and
start with a data set that you
understand and that's why we've selected
these data sets that
come from a background relevant to life
sciences
and so i think many of the people are
more
motivated to continue and learn about a
method once it's
talking about a data set that you
understand so in this case this is gene
expression
for cell lines and those cell lines
could be categorized
in groups based on their type or subtype
of breast cancer and so the first thing
that you will see here are some
important parts of the code that you
have to master
for any kind of a script and in this
case
we have different libraries that will be
used
and these libraries include libraries
which are
packages that include many different
functions that we can pull from
to actually apply to the data set that
we load
the second line here is going to be how
to load this data
so this data exists here on the internet
but how do i put it into the script
right and so that will be there and then
we start working with this data set
to extract only the meaningful portion
of the data
for our analysis and then launch the
analysis now once you learn these
brief steps it's very easy to understand
how we can apply the same technique to
many different types of data
and how to start working with the tables
so here you see some two different
methods the base
method in r and the g plot method in r
for visualizing this data and as you go
through some
additional useful information is going
to be added to the plot
like labeling the plot or even
projecting
the feature significance or how
individual genes
contribute to this principle component
analysis
plot a two-dimensional plot that we're
looking at
so that we can evaluate which genes are
actually responsible
for the separation into different groups
so once you go through some of this
basic explanation in learning the code
you will be able to
try the code yourself and trying the
code
starts from just simply pressing this
button
run okay so just by running this code
right here in the browser
you already get some output and you can
play with this to change things so that
you can see
what is actually going on for example
as you're going through this code
you can see that we can take there are
actually two different methods to
visualize the pca output
output so here you have the basic method
with plot
and here you have a
gg45 so a library to do everything
in a different approach and simply by
deleting this
we can try to run it again
and only get the basic plot right so now
we can separate
the plot into portions that we
understand so we understand
what the first portion did we understand
what the second portion did
in order for me not to forget i can just
reload the full script
and get all of the things that were in
there before so i can actually now
remove this part of it right here
run it again
and only get the gg plot output right
so now i'm working with two different
libraries one is the base library
including in r
and another one is a library called gg45
that i can actually look up online and
see
what does it do right so i can start
looking into all of the different
options for ggfortify
and see what does it do and many of the
experiences that you will have applying
data science
is going to be related to looking at
different packages and seeing
what kinds of additional methods are
going to be used and how are these
methods
actually used by others to use for
example for principal component analysis
so you can always
find these packages on their different
repositories online
okay a question from abu bakr can you
run the code with your own data
excellent question so this is a
code that is going to work anywhere
right
so simply taking this code
right here and copying it to your
clipboard
you can now install r and r
studio on your own computer and run this
code
on the data set that you would like to
analyze
however let's take a look at how this
data was loaded
you can see that the input file is given
via
a url this is a url to a github
repository where we store
all of the data sets that we'll be going
through on your computer
that data set is going to be sitting
somewhere else it's going to be in your
folder
but in a very similar way you're going
to be using the path
instead of a url to a public domain
you'll be using a path on your own
computer and you can do that
by setting up a working directory on
your computer
and then linking to that directory not
through the full path but just giving
the name of the file
so that's something that you can try and
you can also try some of these
downstream codes that are going to be
much
more uh detailed in what kinds of
outputs they provide you with ultimately
leading to a interpretable
result okay so let's take a look here
at the final result of this analysis
you can hover over the individual dots
that represent
samples and you can see that they're
colored
in four different in four different
colors there's the luminal which is pink
basil which is green normal like which
is blue
and cloud and low which are dark blue
now what is this box that we can spin
around
this is essentially a space
of defined by three principal components
the x y and z those are
axes on this in the space four
principal components selected by the top
information that they carry based on how
much
percentage of variance they show
for our data and so just by learning
about these types of outputs
we can start asking questions about
similarity
and differences between these groups of
samples
and how we can actually take a
classification model
to train an algorithm
to identify the samples that we see here
based on feature significance based on
specific genes that are in this data set
and so going step by step through
examples
that you can run right here on the
screen
to more and more and advanced methods
you can see here going beyond the basics
we'll introduce some additional
applications
of statistics for example to understand
confidence levels on this principal
component
and eventually turning this into a data
science problem and the data science
problem is going to basically
tell us that i have a lot of data i have
mined this data and i have identified
some differences between
groups that i can interpret clinically
using phenotypic information
and now i want to address a problem of
finding these types of subtypes
in a different data set and so now we
can
really translate this into a an
algorithm
that will look for specific markers that
will identify
those types of patients or cell lines
that match a certain clinical phenotype
so as a brief introduction to data
science i think this is a good example
that shows us how we can apply
this data-driven approach of data mining
classification training and machine
learning model
and asking the right kinds of questions
to understand
biology and to be able to leverage
these signal points to really address
a major problem which is classification
of different types of cancers especially
based
on biomarkers so genes that we can
detect
and we can then use on big data
to mine those patterns okay so
if there are any other questions you can
go ahead and
put those questions in the chat box and
in the meantime
i would like to return briefly to our
presentation to talk about how
the other components are actually going
to be used
so as i mentioned
this is going to be a program that
combines
live sessions like we have today where
you can
ask questions we can go through code
together and try to run it
maybe on our browser code playground or
maybe on your own computer
compare the outputs and be able to ask
specifically
whether we understand them with
self-guided study materials so materials
that you can then
practice online independently and
be able to validate that you can
actually go
through these questions go through the
same types of challenges and examples
and then receive practical assignments
so in these sessions we'll give you some
assignments
to complete so you can try it
practice it and then test whether you
really understand them
okay so at this moment i would like to
take a pause
and launch a poll so that we can get a
better sense of who's
in this uh session today so
uh so uh let me try launching the poll
okay so nikki if you could please launch
the poll
it seems like it's not possible from my
computer
yes is the pool visible it's launched
from my side yes i
see people okay uh yes
so uh my first question is what is your
level of education or in that matter
what is your designation are you a high
school student an undergrad
or a grad undergraduation that means
bachelor's graduation masters post
graduation
or a phd fellow or a postdoc fellow and
also i would
want to know about your research and
trust so
uh what are your research interests
machine learning data science
infectious diseases or chem informatics
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenetics
or the general bioinformatics and also
we would want to know if you have signed
up on the
omixlogic learn portal and if yes it's
great if not then we i would be sharing
the link with you and you can go ahead
with
uh signing up and creating your profile
thank you everyone for answering i would
keep the poll for more 30 seconds thank
you
okay thank you so much and um while
you're completing that
there's just a couple more things that i
wanted to share
okay so um what i wanted to
add on to this is that in the process of
getting started with data science but
also
getting to a level of understanding as
we already heard from clinton
one of the highest levels of
understanding is when you can
meaningfully apply the methods and
skills that you have acquired
to a project where you can demonstrate
not just that you've memorized some
scripts but that you actually understand
how to
extract meaningful signal interpret it
in biological terms
and be able to present it answering
questions to experts
and others peers like you so to do that
the omixlogic portal incorporates
several features that will help you do
just that the first one is that you will
gain access to these technical
skills that you can practice on given
examples but what if you want to try
an example of a different kind and so
the first thing
that i want to show you is that beyond
just the technical coursework
you will also have access to project
examples
and these include examples in cancer
they include different types
of data from cell lines from animal
models
as well as from patients that also
include some clinical
information you can also look for
infectious diseases where you will find
information on covid19
ebola virus and others
you will be able to find many other
types of examples
that include agriculture biotechnology
neuroscience and many other
examples but beyond that all of the
methods and all of your activity on the
site
is geared towards allowing you to